let's make waffle maker spicy salmon
crispy rice you're going to start with
some Sashimi grade salmon add some soy
sauce some sesame oil some Sriracha some
scallions mix it all up oil our waffle
maker add in our rice I want to make
sure I have enough rice in there that
looks good now we're just gonna keep it
closed and let it cook until golden
brown wow time to take it out beautiful
it's so cute let's add some cucumber or
salmon avocado some more sriracha and
some Cupid Mayo top it off with some
furikake and some more scallions
mmm this is so good there's so many
textures the crispy rice the creamy
avocado the salmon oh